China's infinite quarantine camps are  shutting down in China if your QR code  turns red you're denied access to  grocery stores public transportation and  even if they don't have symptoms at all  you can get rounded up by force and held  in these camps for weeks we're talking  hundreds of thousands of people in just  one Camp even your baby could get taken  away from you and shipped off to a  quarantine camp but with its economy and  shambles and uprisings all over the  country the CCP is backing off good news  guys now you can just leave go isolate  at home and hey we'll even let you go to  the grocery store now if your symptoms  aren't that bad but only if you live in  certain areas turns out the CCP is  letting local governments decide to  continue restrictions while telling the  media see guys we've changed but for now  official word is that